au milieu des décombres les secours
remonte les victimes d'un bombardement
russe à kharkiv sous la pluie des corps
sans vie sont extraits mais il ya aussi
des survivants
j'étais simplement assis en train de
parler avec ma femme et on a été frappé
je n'ai pas compris sur le moment il ya
eu deux ou trois frappes j'ai repris
connaissance dans la cave
selon les autorités des dizaines de
blessés dont des enfants sont à déplorer
les premiers obus sont tombés au petit
matin ce lundi alors que beaucoup
dormait encore comme valentina popovich
hook qui se dit miraculé
j'ai vu de la lumière les lampes des
pompiers et alors j'ai crié je suis là
je sens ils sont entrés dans le hall on
t'a battu la porte et m'ont sorti de là
cette frappe intervient deux jours après
un bombardement meurtrier sur sa civière
une ville de la région de donetsk à
l'est du pays dans la ville voisine de
cramât torse qu toujours sous contrôle
l'ukrainien les habitants vivent aussi
avec la menace des frappes russe
beaucoup manquent de nourriture et
vienne la chercher auprès d'associations
humanitaires
je suis vraiment reconnaissant envers la
ville tous les bénévoles et l'aide
étrangère
certains ont anticipé l'arrivée des
troupes russes et pro russe en faisant
des stocks kiev a prévenu la population
moscou pourrait ici lancé une de ses
plus féroces offensive